seine Leiche wird wohl für immer
verschollen bleiben irgendwo im Meer in
der Karibik 11 Tage nach dem Absturz des
Privatjets des deutschen Multimillionärs
Rainer Schaller vor der Küste von Costa
Rica sind die Suchaktionen jetzt
endgültig eingestellt worden nach wie
vor werdende vier der sechs Personen die
an Bord des Jets waren vermisst neben
unzähligen Trümmern und fragt teilen
konnten auch zwei Leichen bisher
geborgen werden wir sprechen darüber mit
uns unserem korspondenten Herbert Bauer
neben der mir jetzt zugeschaltet ist
einen schönen guten Morgen dir Herbert
es gibt also keine Hoffnung mehr die
Leiche Schallers zu finden
ja die Küstenwache von Costa Rica wie
auch im Zusammenarbeit mit dem
Ministerium veröffentliche Sicherheit
hat 11 Tage lang gesucht wie gesagt am
21 oktober ist die Privatmaschine von
Rainer Schaller mit seiner Familie vom
Radar verschwunden wirklich fündig ist
man nur am ersten Tag geworden als man
eben hier auf rackteile zwei Todesopfer
und Gepäckstücke gefunden hat dann
allerdings absolut nichts mehr bei jedem
weiteren Tag der Suche gab es keine
neuen Resultate keine neuen practteile
und die Suche wurde dann immer weiter
verlängert allerdings hat es nichts
gebracht letztendlich es war eine Suche
nach einer Stecknadel in einem Heuhaufen
natürlich ein Riese ein riesiges
Suchgebiet in der Ausdehnung von 150
Quadratkilometern dass ich sogar bis
hinunter vor die Küste von Panama
erstreckt hat teilweise ist der
Meeresboden hier zwischen 600 und 1200
Meter tief ohne
sozialgeräte wäre hier eine Entdeckung
dieses Wracks komplett unmöglich gewesen
und die Behörden haben auch mitgeteilt
dass Sie davon ausgehen dass die
Maschine durch die Wucht des Aufpralls
in mehrere Teile zerfallen ist um diese
Teile diese Rumpfteile möglicherweise
von der Strömung weggetrieben worden
sind hast du den Eindruck Herbert dass
die Behörden wirklich alles getan haben
um Aufklärung zu betreiben es gibt
weiterhin in diesem tragischen Unglück
so viele offene Fragen
die Behörden in Costa Rica haben
eingesetzt was sie zur Verfügung haben
als kleines mittelamerikanisches Land
man muss sagen es war jetzt keine
riesige suche die abgehalten wurden
jeden Tag meistens war ein Suchflugzeug
unterwegs dazu ein oder zwei Schiffe der
Küstenwache die den mehr am Meer hier
auf und ab patroulliert sind und
Ausschau gehalten habe nach möglichen
Trümmern auf die Frage von mir selbst an
einem der offiziell ob Costa Rica
internationale Hilfe benötigen würde
diese Frage wurde damals
verneint man sagte man hätte alle
Ressourcen es war einfach keine Chance
mehr hier irgendetwas zu finden es war
eine schmerzhafte Entscheidung das sagt
noch die Behörden in Costa Rica man habe
die getroffen er in Kontakt mit den
Angehörigen der Opfer es wurde auch
mitgeteilt dass die Angehörigen eines
der Todesopfer sogar zur Unglücksstelle
gefahren geworden auf die offene See man
hat hier wirklich versucht alles zu tun
es war es fehlte hier halt einfach an
den Ressourcen aber es war auch der
Hauptgrund dass dieses Suchgebiet
einfach zu groß wurde
vielen herzlichen dank dir für die
Informationen in diesem Morgen
[Musik]